everything in your life changes when you
learn to tie your self-worth to your
effort instead of the results most
people tie their self-worth to the
results to winning you only feel good
about yourself when you win if that's
how you think then you're screwed
because that person only takes on
projects that you know you have a pretty
high chance of winning at and therefore
you play small for Life the key is to
tie your self-worth to the effort to try
and if you do that well you'll win
Beyond Your Wildest imaginations so
let's use me as an example look at this
video two minutes before getting on to
making this video I'm nervous I don't
want to do it I'm trying to find a
reason why I don't have to do this video
now why I've done 6 000 of these videos
do I not love it anymore the answer is
because I don't want to make it the same
way that I've done the past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
if you're doing the same thing over and
over and over again it becomes easy but
then you get bored you start to hit your
life you start realizing that everything
is just a photocopy over and over and
over and over and over again with this
pressure on myself to say this video
right now has to be the best video that
I've ever made most days I don't
accomplish it when you're trying
something new and scary and bigger and
Bolder most of the time you won't get it
you fail a lot but I tie my self-worth
my respect to the effort I'm trying and
every now and then you'll make a bit of
a breakthrough and so the answer isn't
have a big goal and then find a reason
why you can't do it the answer is you're
scared and you're gonna do it anyway and
I think that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than me
because most days I get up and fail but
the more you fail the more you're
eventually going to win I'm gonna get
massive results because you tie yourself
Worth to your abilities to get up and
try again and pat yourself on the back
for the effort you're putting in not
just when you're with need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
there it's Mark Traeger and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that's holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside of you as
well you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something so get ready to
focus on the efforts not the result
results find your drive and do difficult
things with my guy Evan Carmichael and
our take on his top 10 rules to success
to give you the confidence the
motivation and the belief that you need
to succeed enjoy
rule number two find your drive most
people quit on things because they don't
have a powerful Mission or they don't
know where their Drive comes from
chasing an opportunity isn't enough
because you're going up against people
who love that thing who might be willing
to die for that thing if you want to go
to Mars you're competing against Elon
Musk who would die to go to Mars you
better absolutely love it or he's going
to crush you you need to find the thing
that you love that does not feel like
work otherwise you'll end up working
your entire life and hating it so every
Thursday when I'm in Toronto I do this
free event for Toronto entrepreneurs at
my dance studio trying to dance salsa
five to six pm Thursdays when I'm in the
city I do a free event q a session for
an hour come out meet me talk let's hang
out however I can help give back to the
community and help local entrepreneurs
my Thursdays are Bonkers my Thursdays
are all day long interviews hang out
it's podcasts Skype sessions one-on-ones
my assistant books them in 25 minute
chunks and I have 25 minutes on five
minute break in between usually I use
that break to get set up for the next
one 25 minutes five twenty five five
twenty five five the whole day long and
then I end up going to the studio I
record my podcast with Mark Drager I
then do two 30-minute one-on-ones that
we filmed for the YouTube channel and
then after all of that I do a one hour q
a for the entrepreneur community and
then after that I'm doing more meetings
with my team
it's crazy and somebody asked me last
Thursday how do you have the energy for
all of that stuff
I love it like I I love
the best for me I love it I'm not
getting paid for it it's free it's
probably not a great use of my time if I
if I had to pick for one hour what's the
best use of my time hang out with
startup entrepreneurs ask me their
questions or or do something like write
my book or make my next course or
something else it probably doesn't make
the most sense but I love it and so
therefore it makes the most sense
right and for other people jumping into
my schedule might be torture and it
should be for me to jump into your
schedule should be torture I should look
at your calendar and say that's
ridiculous how do you have so much
energy for all that stuff and when you
jump in the mind and you look the exact
same for me when I gear up for Thursday
as an example when I put my extrovert
hat on I gain energy as the day goes on
I'm not losing energy by the time I hit
five o'clock and I'm doing the group
session with people I'm carrying the
energy of all the entrepreneurs that
I've met on my 25 minute one-on-ones
throughout the entire day
I love it I gain more steam but most
things ask me to do almost anything else
for for 8 10 12 14 hours I would hate my
life Aspen to make coffee for for 10
hours a day I would hate my life
ask me to play piano ask me to do almost
anything for that amount of time I would
hate my life because it feels like work
and so you have to find the thing that
does not feel like work so then when you
go off and do it it actually gives you
energy so paying attention to the energy
if at the end of every day like oh
oh this sucks like that's a good signal
that you're doing the wrong thing
because you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something you are a genius you
should be crushing it at something and
if the work that you're doing is
draining your energy the people around
you are draining your energy chances are
you're in the wrong spot you're hanging
them with the wrong people you're doing
the wrong kind of work rule number three
do difficult things so steam comes from
doing difficult things you set a goal
you said you'd start doing something and
maybe even you do actually start doing
that thing but then you hit a roadblock
then it gets difficult it gets hard and
what you do in that moment will Define
the rest of your life when it's hard
when it's difficult do you rise to the
occasion or do you let yourself off
again finding some really logical reason
why you can't do that thing it doesn't
count until it's hard you don't grow
until it's hard you don't build
self-respect self-esteem self-confidence
until it's hard and you follow through I
keep these in my office as a reminder of
who I am of who I am in my best moments
my best self to push me to do more and
to push harder what what are these if
you're new to my channel welcome I'm
Evan I went on a tour at the beginning
of this year I did a tour of 23 cities
90 days and two-thirds of the way
through with a month left I broke my
neck when I was in Denver I fainted I
fell out of the chair I hit my head
against the wall cracked my the back of
my head open I had three Staples on my
head I had a concussion and I broke my
neck in two spots
and after that night I had to wear this
I had to wear this for the next
I just noticed this note here Nina
signed it
I love you get well soon Nina she signed
it that's that's sweet
ah gotta go thank her anyway had a
little emotional moment there I broke my
neck and I decided to keep going on my
tour I had a month left everybody was
telling me to go home my agent told me
to go home my friends my family said
come home get get the health care you
need relax stay in bed rest you need to
recover and I said
being with entrepreneurs is my recovery
and pushing through and doing this tour
is my healing one physical healing
because just sitting on the bed all day
is not going to be for someone like me
something that's amazing but two just
just push it through and knowing that I
can right it doesn't count until it's
hard it doesn't count until it's
difficult and then you get up and you do
it and so if you've seen any of the
videos or pictures of me at the events I
went from
standing up and moving around and having
energy to then I had to sit at the front
of a room with pillows behind me and an
ice pack on my shoulder blade for three
and a half four hours in massive pain
the whole time answering questions and
doing my workshop and I was so proud of
myself for doing it that's how I built
my self-esteem by getting up and doing
it by showing up
and it inspired the people who came out
they're saying well I you know I lived
25 minutes away didn't know if I wanted
to make the drive or commit to it I was
kind of tired and then I saw you with
your broken neck still showing up so I
had to show up too
right but that's not why I did it I did
it for me I did it for myself I had to
wear this all day all night long this
was my first one and then it started to
break so Nina put some duct tape on it
here and then this this was my second
one that once it started to really wind
down I couldn't wear it anymore I went
for this one and 10 minutes a day is all
I could do to take it off for a shower
so I had to sleep in this I had to do my
workshop in this everything
23 hours and 50 minutes a day except for
a 10 minute break in the shower where I
took it off and was paranoid about
moving anything because my neck was
broken I had to keep it stabilized I
wore these
this reminds me of how strong I am rule
number four alter your environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you exactly where you are the
people you hang with the videos you
watch the midi you consume all of it are
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now today if you
want to raise your standards it starts
by raising your environment first so a
friend of mine and friend of the channel
Mark Drager from Fanta gave me a really
warm message yesterday and he thanked me
for helping start the process for him to
turn from being a pessimist to an
optimist from being somebody who was
always worried and negative to somebody
who's having more energy who's seen the
light who's becoming more optimistic who
still has a road to go but is so far
further along than where he was before
and he wrote to me to say thank you for
starting me down this path he said there
was one conversation in particular that
had special meaning to him where I told
them that I I just really believed in
him that I saw a lot of the people
around him I saw a lot of his peers and
I just thought that he had so much more
potential than where he was and I think
maybe for the first time he had an extra
bolt of belief pushed into him which is
what I do which is what I'm great at
which is what I enjoy doing fast forward
to now six months eight months later
he's made major gains in his life he's
he's brought on new team members he's
now consuming other content that is
positive and optimistic he's changing
his business around he's investing more
in himself he's happier he's lost a lot
of weight he's he's growing he's wanting
to strengthen his relationships he's
just seen a big shift in his life by
trying to move more into optimism
instead of pessimism and so it started
with my conversation with him he then
promoted somebody within his
organization to become CEO whose name
was Louis and he's also a massive Force
for good and positivity he started
consuming series content which is
positivity he started consuming Tom
billu's content which is positivity he
started now injecting all these these
people and resources into his life to
make him feel more positive more
optimistic more happy give him more
energy so that he has that to go take on
his goals and the challenges are in
front of him and slowly move that needle
from being a pessimist to an optimist I
don't think people are pessimists to be
honest I think everybody is born an
optimist I don't think people are born
negative you know I think that's trained
into you I think you're pessimists and
negative because of the circumstances
you had and what was planted in your
brain by the people around you I think
people are good I think humans are just
good I think if we weren't good we
wouldn't be here anymore
99.99999 of people are good right some
people have a little bit of a miswiring
up there and it causes them to enjoy
killing people but for the most part
we're good I also believe that people
are built to serve
I believe that you get happiness from
helping others by being of service to
others that's what actually makes you
happy there aren't very many happy
moments in your life that didn't involve
somebody else you're helping you are
serving
they've shown the effect on your brain
of serving and helping somebody is the
same as food and sex we're literally
hardwired to help others and to serve
and so if you believe like I believe
that humans are good and humans are
built to serve then what would cause
somebody to be pessimistic and negative
how sad of an upbringing does that
person have to have had
the programming that was installed
inside them by other people who just
were negative and down on their life but
weren't inherently bad people the people
who stole from my car in La the guy who
cut me off in traffic yesterday I don't
think they're bad people I still think
they're good people who are built to
serve just circumstances and
conditioning have led them down a
negative path and so the good news is
you can get out of it just like my
friend Mark has who's someone who would
who was sworn to say I am a pessimist
right I just default to negativity
to now seeing the shift
by changing the people he surrounded
himself with by altering his environment
by consuming content that is more
positive he's already seen a noticeable
shift with a past X number of months and
that's going to continue to grow
that could be you too also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five you have to
believe your biggest problem is a lack
of belief the only thing that's holding
you back holding me back holding your
friends and family back is a lack of
belief it is the world's biggest problem
and that's why I created these YouTube
channels I've seen the impact not just
on the people around me but myself
firsthand myself the value of having my
own channel in the work that I do I make
it selfishly for myself so that I learn
that I get better that I grow that I
challenge myself and it's often hard to
see it on a day-to-day basis you may not
feel a lot more confident have a lot
more belief from one day to the next you
might have some big win you might take
on some big Challenge and then you feel
good about yourself but then you fall
back down the next day and you don't see
that that's actually a win because the
win that you had was so small the growth
that you had was so tiny that on a
day-to-day basis you can't see it that's
the problem but if you consistently are
doing the things like watching this
Channel or consuming a podcast or
reading the book or hanging around
people who are better than you who have
more belief than you who who are growing
and pushing that inspire you if you're
around that every single day and you
look back on your life you look back in
the past X number of months you'll see
how much you've grown you just will I've
seen it in my own business go back and
look at my old content I started a new
series on my other channel where it's
old oven versus new Evan and the first
video we did was 2016 Evan versus 2019
Evan and what do you think and you may
not see that big a difference in me from
last week's video to this week's video
or yesterday's espresso to today's
espresso but when you go back three
years see it doesn't even look like the
same person go back 10 years go back and
watch my first videos go back and watch
their first videos the content was still
good the message was still good but the
delivery the execution
sucked because I didn't know what I was
doing because I didn't have a lot of
belief and I'm still trying to chase the
next level you know I've grown and
believed but I'm never done the thing
that's holding me back it's still belief
it's belief and the ability to get to
the next step because as you expand your
comfort zone
there's still other things that are
outside your comfort zone you don't want
to ever get to the point where you're
not growing where there's not something
outside your comfort zone but then
everything inside becomes easy right
what used to scare you now is super easy
and I wasn't a problem anymore rule
number six make sacrifices there will be
moments in your business where you will
need to have super human strength to
keep going where it just demands
everything from you every single ounce
that you have but if you need to have
superhuman energy every single day
you're gonna burn out and fail so
whenever I want to try something new
when I'm testing something new I always
eat into some of my reserves it may mean
to go off into this project I'm going to
sleep less I spent a little bit less
time working on my book or a little less
time working my YouTube channel right
you eat into these Reserves but that's
not sustainable if that's what you're
doing constantly you're going to be
unhappy you're going to burn out you're
going to fail so quick example uh sad
Guru came to Toronto sad Guru if you
don't know he's a yogi he's a Indian
Mystic we did a top 10 on him he then
invited me to come to his event in
Toronto and then do a one-on-one
interview with him uh close to the
Toronto Airport the island was amazing
great time out of that he says Evan I
want you to come to my multi-day event
in the US I want you to come be a VP
guest there it'd be amazing to have you
awesome but before you do that you have
to do my seven day program where you
have to meditate every day for seven
days and I think it's an hour plus every
day I didn't have an hour a day right I
mean that's not part of what I had in my
calendar
every hour in my calendar is accounted
for it doesn't mean I'm working all that
time but I might be spending time with
my wife I'd be spending time with my son
and every every hour is accounted for
and so to do this I had to eat into some
of my reserves and so for that one I
asked Nina said Nina
if you're gonna come with me you have to
do this too do we want to spend our hour
in the evening instead of watching a
show instead of relaxing to to do this
program for seven days for meditation
and she said yes
and so here's the thing we did it for
seven days and we went to the event it
was awesome if it was something that we
were going to continue
if we're gonna meditate every day for an
hour ongoing then I'd have to readjust
my schedule your success comes from your
habits you need to figure what a
balanced life looks like for you now
ultimately I don't meditate an hour
every night I do some healing meditation
for my neck every morning but that habit
didn't stick and that's okay so when
you're testing new habits testing an
idea is testing something for your
business or some emergency comes up that
you have to deal with it's going to tap
into your reserves you can't be running
your business at full capacity already
you can't be running your business on
zero on empty because that means there's
no extra gear that means that when life
punches you in the face you can't handle
it that means if you want to try or
taste or test something else you can't
do it because you have no reserves you
have no battery there's no more gas in
the tank and so that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs live that that's where
it's really Troublesome that's where a
lot of entrepreneurs will end up burning
out failing and crushing their dreams
because you're just running with no gas
left
and so you can stretch yourself I think
that's normal I think that's okay I
think life will hit you in the face and
just when you think it couldn't get
worse here comes another punch that will
happen but it's making sure that you can
live that Balanced Life whatever balance
looks like for you rule number seven you
have to hold yourself accountable you
need people in your life to hold you
accountable because you will never push
yourself as hard as you can go you get a
personal trainer not because of what
exercises you should do you can look
that up online the real value of a
trainer is to have somebody right there
in front of you in your face telling you
to do three more reps of that exercise
when you want to quit when you're gonna
tap out and if you were by yourself
you'd say I'm done and they say give me
three more because all of the growth
happens in that last set if there's
nobody around you to hold you to a
higher standard you'll always know that
there's another level but you'll be too
afraid to reach for yourself so let's
use me as an example
I want to solve the world's biggest
problem I don't think people believe in
themselves enough it's why I created
this Channel and all the other ones I
have and the books and the speaking
everything I do I want to go out and do
this impossible thing that's never going
to happen I'm never gonna solve the
world's biggest problem and yet I wake
up every day and I try to do it and I
use a combination of what I call
aspirational mentors which are people
like Steve Jobs and Elon Musk and the
people that I profile on this channel
and then I also do it from people who
challenge me one-on-one if you watch my
entrepreneur advice Channel I get pushed
every week by my agent Steve by
psychologists in Australia by people who
are coaching me and I had to get better
and they push me and they tell me I need
to do more and they tell me I'm being an
idiot in these areas and like go this is
the homework
and the more uncomfortable I feel during
that process usually the better the
advice is
if I think about the tour that I
launched last year and now the tour that
I'm doing this year
it started as a free tour and became a
paid tour when my agency pushed me to do
it
you need to charge for this and
immediately my heart's boom boom boom
boom boom I'm scared means I have to do
it
having people around you who can push
you to do the things that you need to do
who make you nervous who make you scared
who see your blind spots who cut through
your BS
who tell you that's just fear talking
because we'll come up with really
logical reasons why we can't do
something
or aspirational mentors who when you see
how they react to things how they see
things how they understand the world and
then you look at what you're doing it
forces you to be pulled up it forces you
to take the next step up on the
staircase you need to do it because your
environment's been perfectly designed to
keep you where you are your friends your
family all of it it's keeping you
exactly where you are and the difference
between where you are now and where you
want to be and where you can be in a
year in two years in five years in 10
years is going to be the people you have
around you and how much they're willing
to push you to believe in you to tell
you what you may not want to hear but
you need to hear to grow to challenge
yourself and get to the next level rule
number eight own your dreams when did
you decide that your dreams shouldn't be
big when did you decide that you
shouldn't tell anyone else about your
dreams until you own your dreams and
stop making yourself feel small those
dreams will never happen never now this
is something everybody struggles with
everybody myself Mel everybody we're
worried about playing a bigger game
we're worried about thinking bigger for
ourselves and we're worried about
telling other people because what if it
doesn't work out what if we don't make
it what's that judgment gonna come how
are they going to think about us and so
I think about my own story when I'm
trying to create the biggest fight that
I used to get into with my agent Steve
was he says Evan you need to be a
household name you need to be famous
like Steve I don't want to be famous
i i i equated famous to Ego if you're
famous and you're just big egomaniac I
didn't I don't want to be an egomaniac
it's not it's not about me it's about
spreading belief I don't I'm nervous
getting in front of the camera even
before filming this video I'm nervous
like I wanted to wanted to do well the
lights come on I don't crave it I don't
crave attention I'm an introvert I like
just doing my thing Evan you need to get
famous why Steve why do we need to get
famous
and for maybe two years we fought over
this because I kept equating Fame with
ego and I looked at the people who were
famous and like I don't want to be like
them and there's a lot that they did
that that bothered me and I wanted to do
it a different way and that's the key
it's finding the different way to do it
how does an introvert on a mission
become famous I don't know we're gonna
go on this journey together and
hopefully find out what finally a click
for me was him saying when you get
famous your mission will spread
if you start tying actions to Mission
that's how you get me to move for other
people it might be hey I'll give you all
this money if you do this or you'll have
the fame or or credibility or have
statues but I don't need statues built
of me but as soon as you tie it to
Mission and service that gets me going
so he said if you actually want
to fulfill your mission if you say you
want to spread belief then you need to
get famous because the more people know
about you the more people will hear your
message and if finally it finally stuck
like okay I gotta do it I don't know how
to do it I've never I've never tried to
do it I've I've always wanted to be
behind the spotlight and so now now this
is part of my mission I need to become a
household name and get famous so that
more people can believe in themselves if
I actually want to solve the world's
biggest problem
then I need to be out there doing it I
need to believe in myself more
right if I'm trying to spread belief I
need to believe in myself more too
and so I think that's a human condition
that's part of what we want to do you
want to step outside your comfort zone
you want to serve humans are built to
serve we are we are built to serve but
service requires helping other people
and because we're afraid of judgment
you don't want to do it so you've got
your foot in the gas and a break at the
same time you want to help people but
you're worried about their judgment so
you don't do anything you know you're
capable of more you know you're capable
of more but you don't do it because
you're afraid rule number nine you have
to kick yourself forward turn yourself
to other people can be a fantastic thing
a fantastic thing but there's only one
way to make it work you have to kick
yourself forward not down you kick
yourself forward not down most people
here's what they do most people you see
someone who's had success you see
somebody with a Ferrari or the car or
somebody who you're jealous of or you're
insecure about yourself when you're
around them you see them and you you
think you suck you look at them and say
I suck why am I not further ahead why is
Dan who's not even 40 years old yet have
all of the success and here I am and I'm
not doing it yet right you kick yourself
down that's how most people do it and in
public you might tell your friends how
that person's a scumbag you stole he's
ripping people off he's a jerk but when
you go home you just tell yourself man
why am I not for their head why am I why
am I here why am I stuck why am I not
getting more momentum you've been kicked
but you've been kicked down
where what you want to do is kick
yourself forward
you want to kick yourself forward if you
see Dan driving his Ferrari or you see
somebody that you look up to and respect
use it as a kick forward to say this is
what's possible this is what's possible
and if he can do it if she can do it
then I can do it too
my hero is Young Les Brown I love him
from a speaker just my favorite speaker
of all time I look at that and I say I
can get better
not that I suck it's that this is what's
possible I need to get better I need to
improve I need to practice I need to
keep going because that's what's
possible and Rule Number 10 the last one
before our very special bonus tip never
give up Paul Newman the legendary actor
had an amazing quote that I love to
repeat he said I check my pulse and if I
can find it I know I've got a chance
you've got a very important choice to
make you either make the rest of your
life the best of your life or you settle
for what is and live in your excuses so
you know why I would give up you know
what I'm deeply afraid of I've got two
I've got a short-term fear and a
long-term fear my short-term fear is of
disappointing people my biggest short
term in the moment fear is disappointing
people that I would show up to an event
and let people down that I wouldn't give
them value that people would come and
waste their time spend their money and I
didn't give them value I'm deeply afraid
of it and still that I put pressure on
these videos cause I want these videos
to be great every time I get in front of
this camera and start making a video I
put pressure on myself that this seems
to be the best video that I've ever done
I want to not disappoint you guys every
single time and this little pause
hesitation before filming and I'll I'll
spend a couple minutes procrastinating
because I'm I'm afraid I'm afraid of
disappointing you and making a crappy
video I'll procrastinate
and then I'll do it and I'll feel great
at doing it but my biggest short-term
fear disappointing people my biggest
long-term fear is of regret is that I
won't live my life is that I'll look
back and say I could have done more I I
should have pushed harder because you
rarely regret the things that you did
it's the things that you didn't do the
things you were too afraid to do the
action's not taken that's what you
normally regret
and so my biggest short-term fear is
disappointing people maybe because the
long-term fear is fear of regret and
those things
they fight each other
right they fight each other because if
I'm afraid of disappointing somebody I'm
not going to take the action that I
should be taking and then I'm going to
regret it later on and so I try to use
that to your potential regret to push me
into action to say if I don't make
videos today if I don't do that speech
if I don't get up and make that
presentation if I don't do the thing
that I'm afraid to do
because of disappointing people
potentially then I'll regret it and I'll
put the pressure like this is the video
this video right here this is the video
that's gonna blow up everything that'll
change the whole game for me and if I
don't record it because I'm afraid of
disappointing somebody I'm gonna regret
that my whole life and I make it so
painful for myself that then I have to
act and that pain pushes me into action
and out of procrastination mode
I think we play small by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we haven't
trained in us from a young age our
parents our family our friends our
teachers think about who did you learn
about life from probably people who
didn't like their own life you know who
did you learn about careers from
probably people who did not have a great
career you know who barely are enjoying
what they're doing in their work and
they're living in scarcity mindset of
this is all I can do and that's what
we've learned from and you know guidance
counselors at school do they love what
they're doing I mean I think this is a
huge problem and we're stuck living
small and living scared and living as a
result way below our potential of what
we could do and who we could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problems when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially at the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limiting
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wins without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
who never accomplish their goals who
don't end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both
and so if you're not working hard then
you don't have a shot but assume when
you are working hard and you want a 10x
again then it's a shift in mindset and
the shift in living beliefs so how do
you identify the living beliefs how do
you figure out where it's holding you
back how do you break through the
Paradigm and hit a new level a lot of it
is environmental
the current thinking that you have was
environmental it's your parents and your
family and your guidance counselor and
teachers and family Etc that's
environmental you've adopted their
beliefs and unfortunately a lot of them
are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever is more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people every day but
you know we can't so how do you do it
well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
I think when you're around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter and when somebody
asked me yesterday on Instagram do I
think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
said no I don't think you'll buy Twitter
but it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
in general right you know lots of people
have underestimated him and he's proven
them wrong many many many times and I
just like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk logically be
thinking through it if you're if you
were running Tesla uh in SpaceX would
you have thought about buying Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at this hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if you
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove
but the groove can also be a rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expansive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors what I call them an Elon Musk a
John Assaraf I Oprah Winfrey people who
who you may never meet but you can still
learn a heck of a lot from
step two was to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you're in that things that used to
make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
conference an event you come back I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just just think about if
you're just constantly stuck it doesn't
mean you have to go travel on vacation
it may mean you take up salsa dancing it
may mean you try a new hobby take that
idea that you've got and just go go to
it look at any events that are happening
in your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful computer at the time with with
unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class that you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at but he
wouldn't have known that unless he
dropped out of school and dropped in on
the calligraphy class so it's changing
the environments being a part of new
things it's it's not just staying stuck
in the same habit the same routines and
and same thing you're doing constantly
and that will inject newness that will
then allow you to be more creative and
create amazing opportunities for your
next goals so step one is to be around
aspirational mentors to be around the
people like an Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey
Etc watching videos content interviews
podcasts books that make you feel better
stronger more courageous step two is to
get out of your comfort zone and go go
to things physical things travel more
take take on classes say yes go to
conferences and events just so that you
expose yourself to new ideas and
opportunities and come up with fresher
ideas of what you could do with your
life and step three is to to actually
have humans in your life who you're
around who make you want to push and do
more and be better and this mean I hey
if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
Movie Makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know it's not Movie
Maker is something else but being around
other people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated I felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really struggled so find other
people who are on this journey that you
can do it with because when you feel
like you're doing it with other people
and you're not alone you'll be a lot
more productive a lot more effective and
have a lot more fun as well most people
don't get what they want because you
don't follow through enough you just
don't follow through it's based out of
insecurity you start and stop start and
stop you're afraid of hurting people's
feelings you're afraid of what they're
gonna say about you you're afraid
they're gonna judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume so we we stop we stop
and try to do something else where we're
seeing more immediate results but if
it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stores is with Brendan Bouchard
and I went to speak at his event in
Phoenix and I knew of him but I didn't
know him at the time it was his business
partner that had me come out to his
event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help or you know what's
next for you and I said I won't work on
my book and he said I'd love to uh I'd
love to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone uh number and I said how about
email and he said oh I'm not really good
on email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then uh he
said oh man thank you uh I'm super
swamped right now but uh let's either do
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oh I don't want to
bother him
maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out uh maybe
I'm offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's the busy guy he had a lot of stuff
going on he had a launch that was
happening that I wasn't even aware of uh
that he was planning behind the scenes
and so he is he was you know not crazy
stressed out but he just has a lot on
his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
just one more email that's it I'm gonna
send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or whatever
and he he wrote back an email and like
hey sorry man again I'm not super great
on email I've just been swamped planning
all these things uh yeah come on out
come out to the event speak at the event
too and that was his big event that was
you know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind
to be a part of that then I spoke on
stage that then at the event after I
spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis Howes and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses
all of that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up and I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence and and I and the reasons
why you're not doing it are based in
reality right I mean I could be
overwhelming it's possible it's possible
that he thinks that I'm overwhelming
that I'm not given enough value that I'm
being too selfish that I'm bothering him
I mean it's possible but we default to
just assuming that instead of actually
finding out
and we miss out on a lot of upside and
so here's what I found that really helps
one you schedule it in
schedule it in every X number of weeks
right so every two weeks I would send in
another email every two weeks every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks every two weeks and I
never felt like doing it because every
time I saw that in my task list
I I didn't want to do it like you know
let's give it another let's give it
another few days let's give it another
week you know I never wanted to do it
but because it was in my calendar I did
it you will never want to do it because
you're afraid right underneath it is
really just fear it's insecurity you'll
never want to do it so you schedule it
in every two weeks or every week or
every month or whatever the thing is
that makes sense for the timeline that
you're on
you schedule it in so that you have to
do it
so when it came up I knew I had even
though I didn't want to even though my
heart was beaten I was like
I still went off and I did it second
thing is
lead with the intention before you write
the email before you make the call
before you do the follow-up like what's
the intention is your intention to screw
this person over is your intention to
just suck up their time is your
intention to negotiate a bad deal for
them hopefully not
if you're if you're a subscriber of this
channel uh hopefully it's with its
positivity and hope and belief and and
mutual you know uh benefits and so if
you lead with that intention every time
it's really unlikely that they're going
to
come back in a really negative way
the truth of the matter is they're
probably just really busy maybe they're
doing something
insane in their life maybe they have a
health scare maybe they're in the
hospital maybe their mom's in the
hospital right like you never know
what's going on behind the scenes
and if you leave with intention as
opposed to a copy paste email or just
some kind of spam if you if you leave
with I love this person I want to do
something with them I want to help I I
want to I want to learn if that's a
positive intention going in your your
call your email your follow-up will just
be a lot better it'll be a lot better
and people will feel it I forget who it
was I want to say it was
I forget who it is I'm thinking princess
dive I don't think it was her I wanna I
don't forget who it was where she would
say before I send an email
I would always smile
I would think about the person
and I would smile before I I wrote an
email or wrote a letter
and it would always change
the the vibe of the letter right like if
you're thinking love kindness smiling
before you make a video before you do a
DM before you do a uh an email right
like if you're thinking that
chances are you'll make them smile
you know like if you're smiling
before you do it you're probably gonna
make them smile
and so just taking that little pause to
reflect on what is my intention here
instead of defaulting to insecurity and
the stress on your side
default into let's lead with positivity
let's smile let's leave with love
you'd be amazed at how many great things
happen
so those two things
one you put in your calendar
until you get a response like if
somebody if somebody says no
okay
at least you got a response
but again it's likely going to be a
loving no because you followed up so
many times and you've always LED with a
positive intention and love and kindness
they might just say I'm just you know
what I can't do this right now or I'm
not interested or
or hey sorry I haven't gotten back to
you let's do this
right A lot of times it's just a timing
a lot of times your timing is way off
and it's not your timing it just doesn't
fit into their life or their world right
now but in two weeks it might or in two
months it might or in two years it might
and if you're following up every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks and you're leading with
love and kindness and with a positive
intent amazing things will happen
you have a great Mission inside you
you have a desire to serve and the help
and to create great things for the
people who you work with
right like that that is at the core of
Who You Are
and that needs to be spread
and at the beginning when people don't
know who you are it's a little harder to
get attention to get on people's radar
but if you are consistently following
through consistently even in the face of
not getting any response you just
consistently because it's on your
calendar you're consistently following
through and you're leading with the
intention of Love kindness positivity
great things will happen
I promise you great things will happen
some businesses are just easier to build
on the scale than others some businesses
have a high growth market and some of
them are slow growth it doesn't mean
that you can't win but the opportunity
is going to be much different the upside
is going to be much different depending
on the market that you're going into
I'd love to say that a successful
entrepreneur is one who combines what
you love doing with the word as an
opportunity if you love doing it but
there's no opportunity or it's really
small then you've got a hobby it can be
really fulfilling hobby but it's when
you love doing it and there's a big
opportunity that's when you start to win
now if there's a big opportunity you
don't love doing it you're not going to
win either you can build an okay
business if there's a big opportunity
but you don't like doing it but only for
so long because then you're gonna quit
you're going to hate your life because
you're waking up every day and doing
work that you don't like doing and
you're gonna quit and this is where a
lot of entrepreneurs struggle they do
one of those two things they try to
start a business just around their
Hobbies their what they're passionate
about but there's no Market opportunity
they don't know how to tie it into real
demand so they never build a business
just a hobby on the weekends any events
or
they're just chasing the hot opportunity
and they don't care about the business
and so either way you're going to lose
in both those scenarios you win by doing
the work that you love
that has a big opportunity upside to you
as well I want to share two quick
examples uh that happened to me in the
past week that I think could be really
relevant and valuable one was a dear
friend of mine asked me what social
media platforms am I focusing on and
we're talking about Instagram because he
he wants to go more hardcore Instagram
want to know what I was doing on
Instagram and I said you know what right
now I'm not doing much on Instagram
you know I'm not spending a lot of my
effort my time my energy on Instagram I
love serving I love helping I love
getting a message out there I want to do
it in a way that has the biggest
potential or impact and reach in the
projects I'm working on so he said well
where are you spending your effort and
energy well YouTube was still number one
YouTube was number one because YouTube
is still the best place to get your
message across
it has been for the past couple years
and it's only getting bigger more people
are going to YouTube for content for
Education it's only getting bigger so
YouTube is still number one but then
after YouTube where am I spending most
of my time
Twitter
and Discord Discord I think is the best
place to be for community and Twitter
it's surprising how how much Twitter has
picked up Twitter was one of the first
social networks I was on and I I not
left it but kind of ignored it for years
and now it's back it's back baby so I'm
spending a lot of my time on Twitter and
Discord and of course YouTube
and why well because that's where people
are that's where the impact is that's
where you get your message out and so I
don't care about the platform I care
about reaching people so you could spend
all day long working on on Instagram or
you could have spent all day long still
if you were working on MySpace creating
your account does mystery still exist I
don't even know
it's just not a big opportunity
and so yeah again what do I care about I
care about helping entrepreneurs I care
about getting a message out there so
then it becomes using your head okay
where's the opportunity YouTube Discord
Twitter PS if you want to join my
Discord server it's free I'm there every
day Evan carmichael.biz come check us
out
example was I'm talking to a successful
entrepreneur who wants to move from his
big business that he's built tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue to
starting a business to help other
entrepreneurs get their companies going
and he's having a hard time getting this
thing off the ground and is having a
hard time monetizing it
[Music]
and he's having a hard time getting
people to pay him for things
and I said well the immediate
opportunity you know if you have a long
Horizon great you'll you'll eventually
win because your brain will play out
you'll get better at them at the game
Etc but
the best thing you can do right now if
you want to monetize it is coach people
who are
inside of your industry that you have
domain expertise because what he's
coming out doing is just helping people
with personal development coming in
helping them believe in themselves
helping them overcome their living
beliefs you know helping them
fixed our mindset get their schedule
right all that stuff but then if they're
off building their own business
he's only adding one little piece now
imagine if you could add the tactical
information in the contacts as well as
the mindset and the motivation so
there's two entrepreneurs three
entrepreneurs that I invested into
recently Drew
Jeremy and Bo and these three guys
some of them had no experience I think
Jeremy had he was a stock boy at a
grocery store and you know he's made six
figures Revenue 18 months later why well
because yes I'm giving him the belief in
the mindset and the motivation but I can
also give him contacts I can also make
introductions for him I can also give
him information about the industry to
know what he's doing right and what he's
doing wrong and so when I'm looking at
making an investment into an
entrepreneur I want to be able to help
them Beyond just believe because I can
get believed anybody but who would I
want to give believe to that had the
highest impact for success is going to
be people who I can give contacts to
Jeremy does YouTube Consulting there's
people who contact me all the time for
YouTube Consulting I don't want to do it
I don't want to be in that business so I
can give it to Jeremy perfect but if you
were a you know I don't know you were an
arborist can you see the trees I guess
that it's kind of blurry
um if you're an arborist I could help
you believe in yourself I can give you
some business model ideas but I can't
make contacts or introductions for you
and so you have to be smart about the
opportunities you take on
has to be something that you
deeply deeply deeply care about
and then inside that find the
opportunity
because the market is moving and the
market hopefully is getting bigger and
if you're inside a growing market and
you love what you're doing that's a slam
dunk that's a home run for you so
what's the methodology now to help
figure that out well one you have to
start with what do you naturally just
love doing what do you love doing what
can you wake up and get what do you what
are you getting lost in where are you
spending your time what are you
daydreaming about don't not about the
result not about the cars and the yachts
and the whatever right not that that
that's a result that what do you get
lost in the process of doing what
industry do you actually care about
where are you spending your time where
are you researching what doesn't feel
like work for you right so that's Step
One is is connecting to something that
you're actually passionate about not
just trying to make money right making
money is important but it's not step
number one
figure out that idea next is okay how do
we turn that into a market opportunity
where is the business actually growing
that we can connect our our talents and
our passions to so if you love send if
you love sharing a message like my first
example great now be strategic about the
platform that you're going to pick
it used to be Instagram now it's YouTube
Twitter and Discord
if you love coaching people and
Consulting and investing in people great
connected to where you actually have
domain expertise and can make
introductions for people and take a
piece of their business as opposed to
just charging for the hour
or just helping people with mindset and
not actually introductions and tactics
right so you love the opportunity it
makes you come alive thinking about it
and
there's actually something for you to
grow
right logically strategically is a way
for you to make money doing it when you
can combine those two things you have a
much much much much much much higher
degree of success my key to being
productive is doing different things on
different days different activities
different energy states on different
days if you feel like you're getting to
the end of the day or getting to the end
of the week and you're working like
crazy like you're working you you were
not sucking off you're working like
crazy and yet nothing seemed to happen
have you gotten there it's like I did so
much work this week and yet I've moved
very little towards actually
accomplishing my goals if that's you
the way to change it is to realize that
you're flipping between energy states
too much and you're not you're not
tapping into your true productivity so
let me share with you what I do and
hopefully that gives you some value to
planning your schedule in your life as
well
different tasks on different days I'll
break down for you what I do every day
of the week
Monday is my mentoring day Mondays are
the days where I spend mentoring my team
and we've got 37 people on my team
there's a bunch of people who've
invested into as well in their companies
and Monday I just spend the whole day
talking to them all I have to worry
about is mentoring the people on my team
Tuesday is YouTube day so today I'm
filming on a Tuesday I don't know what
day this video is being released but
it's a Tuesday for me filming all I have
to worry about on a Tuesday is making
YouTube content and why it's so
productive these days is because it
takes a while to make the first video it
takes a while to do the first call takes
a while to get momentum going but once
you get the momentum going
it's easier to stain the momentum than
if you switch to something else it takes
a lot longer to get into that momentum
so quick example it's YouTube day for me
it took me 15 minutes to get ready for
the first video and not get ready like I
have to do my hair
get ready just emotionally get ready
mentally get get ready not procrastinate
get ready to bring the energy and have
the right Vibe and feel good enough and
and all of the stuff it takes took me 15
minutes to get ready and then the first
video
it takes it takes a while to get the
Mojo going and then after the first
video the second one is better and the
third one is better this is my fourth
one recording is better and now it's
easier to go right and so in the time it
takes me to make one video the first
video I could then in that same amount
of time go make three or four videos
intermediate intermediate I want to say
sequential that's not a word succession
succession intermediate succession
whatever
after I can make three or four more
videos right after while I'm in that
same Vibe so same thing for you whatever
Vibe you're feeling if you can stay in
that energy Zone instead of switching if
I did YouTube video then write in a book
then doing a phone call that meant for
my team then you're just bouncing around
too much in this high high high energy
switching costs that then keep you
unproductive then this is I mean a huge
unlock because when you can figure out
how to chunk your time like this brain
fog goes away productivity dramatically
increases you suddenly have a lot more
free time as well to do whatever you
want to do Nina is back she's in the
house we are at Nina's acupuncture let
me put my seatbelt on as we well as we
get ready to go
so Tuesday's YouTube day and I spend the
whole day making videos Wednesday is
Project day and on Project day I focus
on whatever projects I want to work on
and it's
I wake up in the morning I look at what
I want to work on today and it's a it's
a lot more of a creative day Tuesdays
and Thursdays are very intense
productive days Wednesday is a
free-flowing day which is not very
productive but very creative what I had
to understand is creativity is messy and
creativity is not productive so judge
myself harshly when I was working on a
new project and it would take me a long
time and I felt like I got nothing done
that's okay creativity is not meant to
be efficient
so you won't be efficient on your
creative days on your creative tasks it
won't be efficient for you but that's
okay and I think you need to have
creative time built into your calendar
because if you're only doing things that
are productive you're going to burn out
you're gonna hate your life and you're
gonna feel Limited
you ever get bored of your own business
you get bored of the things you're doing
well there's not enough creative time
planned into your week when do you get
time to work on new fun things that
maybe pay off maybe don't pay off when
you have time to work on that well you
don't okay so that's when people have
midlife crisis or burnout or want to
throw it all away or quit or stop doing
this thing and so I think you have to
have some highly productive days where
you're really working on achieving the
goals that you know I have to get these
things done and then you have to have
some creative days where you get to
focus on whatever projects you want that
you're not judging yourself harshly for
being you know not very efficient
creativity is messy it's designed to be
that way and you need to have some
creative days in your calendar or you
will get tired of your business and hate
your life so that's Wednesday
Wednesday's creative Day project day
Thursday is public facing day and
Thursdays
I'm usually starting the day with either
movement makers or brand lytics and I'm
I'm introverted and shy and that doesn't
come across in these videos but I am and
it takes me a while to to get into the
zone of being around other people
[Laughter]
so on Thursdays I start with my family
and Movie Makers are my community of
thought leaders are trying to build
their business and get their message to
the world and Brent Linux is my
community of people on YouTube who want
to build their YouTube channel up
specifically and want the advice to to
grow and create and so I start my
Thursdays with them because it's it's
family it's safe it's friendly it's warm
and it makes me feel like what I do
matters and is important and then the
rest of Thursday is interviews and
podcasts and in Zoom calls and just all
day spreading the message
spreading the message you know we got we
got believed to put out there and it's
easy to go off and do those things now
because I just came from movement makers
or brand Linux
so I'm already in the in the zone of
sharing and creating and impacting and
seeing smiles and so I carry that energy
into my next interview on my next
podcast and the next thing that I'm
doing so if I'm booking to be on other
people's shows even if I'm booking for
my own show Thursdays it's always on a
Thursday it's always on a Thursday it's
always on a Thursday and I have five
minute breaks in between so it's usually
25 minutes or 55 minutes and then five
minute break and then on to the next one
on to the next one and so it's really
easy and all of a sudden it's seven
o'clock and
what happened to today I don't know but
amazing things happened because you're
all in that energy and you know do tons
of different shows and episodes and it's
again so much easier to be in that in
that one zone than to then go make a
YouTube video or then go and wrap my
book or then you know book writing was a
creative project so it's on a Wednesday
it took me an hour just to get into
remembering what I did yesterday or last
week on my book right so if you only
give yourself an hour to write the book
that would be absolute waste of time
because it took me an hour to remember
where I left off last time
uh since there's a public-facing day
Friday is CEO day so that's what do we
need to do to grow my business you know
what what are the big projects instead
of working in my business work on the
business so Wednesday's work in the
business on Creative projects Friday is
if I'm going to be the CEO of my
business what does that look like what
do I need to be doing because if you're
an entrepreneur you're you're the CEO
you're probably the janitor as well if
you're a one-person show and we have to
do a lot of things to drive the business
forward we have to be in our business we
don't have a giant team yet even at 37
people I do a lot of work in the
business as opposed to only just being
the CEO and just managing and
truthfully I like being in the business
I like like making videos like this is
not CEO time this is me being in the
business but I like it you know I think
I think people who often just be the CEO
if you're entrepreneurial and there's no
projects you're working on uh you you
grow distant from the business you don't
enjoy it so we all need time in our
calendar every week to focus on being
the CEO and now I spend all my Fridays
doing it at the beginning I just started
with two hours so two hours in my
calendar this is my CEO time and I
blocked it off and I made it important
and when I started doing that I started
seeing more results in my company
Saturday we applied to the weekends too
Saturday is fun day so Saturday spending
time with Nia doing whatever you know
going and starting to get warm here in
Canada you can you can see you know the
grass finally green so if we're going
for a hike or trying out a restaurant or
going to a street festival or just
something fun Sunday is family at midday
so all of the stuff that we have to do
to manage the family you know go grocery
shopping fold laundry clean up the house
family admin kind of stuff that's on a
Sunday and then repeat the next day so
again quick summary Monday is mentoring
day Tuesday is YouTube day Wednesday's
project day Thursday is public facing
day Friday CEO day Saturday fun day and
Sunday is family admin day and that fits
my life
you know that's a calendar for my life
it won't photocopy perfectly over to
yours but the key is to chunk your time
and think about what is a balanced life
look like for me so that
I'm happy I'm creative I'm productive
I'm moving closer to becoming the person
that I want to be and if you can't
control
your calendar fully maybe you have a job
maybe you have other responsibilities
maybe you're still stuck doing some
things you don't want to do that's cool
don't don't stress out and worry about
oh I can't I can't completely control my
day I can't have a YouTube day okay
don't worry about it you have some
controllable time focus on the control
of the time you have and just be more
intentional with it
so that you're not wasting time
scrolling through Instagram posts or
YouTube videos mindlessly that that
you're you're there with intention and
you're gonna you have so many you have a
certain amount of controllable hours I
think part of the advantage of being an
entrepreneur is we have a lot more
controllable hours right if you're a
full-time entrepreneur you get the
control sure we have to you know
be uh
be responsive to our customers but we
don't have a boss
and we get to choose when we show up and
we get to choose what our calendar looks
like and that's part of the Allure being
an entrepreneur is that freedom but if
you're not completely there yet you
still have controllable hours when you
get home from work to the time you go to
bed when you wake up to the time you go
to work and then on weekends you have
controllable hours
be more intentional with them and decide
what is the life that you want to live
that'll come down to then the habits
that you're executing on daily which
comes down to your calendar
and when you can chunk similar tasks
together
when you can stay in the same energy
Zone instead of switching between a
million different tasks every day it
allows you to be more productive it
allows you to be more effective it
allows you to be happier it allows you
to get a lot closer to your goals think
big act small
think big have a big call Big Dreams big
desires big mission big big Vision
You're Gonna Change the World think big
let's go we love that as entrepreneurs
right let's think big and change the
world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us and
nobody's seeing us I just finished this
seven day challenge uh and built to
serve helping people become thought
leaders and people are afraid of people
watching their content and what their
what those people are gonna say and
they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there any
wonder why you're not making is there
any wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making the
the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look in your wardrobe and is
there any wonder why you're still stuck
on that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear
and the thing that's missing is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not going to be
very good probably
but that's okay it doesn't mean you suck
as a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and you don't meet those
expectations in this Gap this is the gap
that prevents you from taking further
action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you recorded a video
watched it back were completely
embarrassed by yourself and then never
posted it and never launched your
channel there's been people who I've
done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent interview
but the insecurities interference and
the doubts creep in and so they don't
they don't post it they don't do
anything about it where you just need to
expect a suck at the beginning
just expect a suck expected to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's there's a
bunch of skills that you need to pick up
and learn and like any other skill you
can learn it of course you can learn it
pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having the skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the trading education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movie makers
uh his name is Michael he's an amazing
human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of asking people to be on the
show and him being the interview were he
was fine being an interviewee when
people were asking him questions but he
didn't want to be the interviewer and
was afraid to ask people questions and
so we had a discussion and we came up
with a concept where it was
um his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with the concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation had a
guest come on and he was doing the
interview and it was the idea to action
that made all the difference because
he'd been thinking about doing a show
and thinking about making content and
you know being too afraid and being
stuck in his head like all of us do
myself included all of us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of the show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expected to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better and a little bit better and when
you look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days
100 days you'll come back and say holy
cow I'm really getting better why
because you developed a skill you were
you were still the same awesome human
now you're developing the skill set to
actually get better at the thing that
you want to do makes all the difference
the only thing you're missing is
momentum so just repeat yourself repeat
to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
oh you're missing is momentum you're
just not doing enough and that's not
that's not a beat down to say judge
yourself and you suck again as a person
and you should be doing more don't do
that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that helped me that that that
gives me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the bar is solo that there is
no bar and that gives you permission to
just start and to create the momentum
you're looking for the other thing that
I find really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes to you for something you
want to do trust it is a good idea trust
that that is the right idea for you that
you should do it that you should take
action on it and that it's going to
serve if you're in a positive mindset
right if you're if you're in a negative
mindset then then it's good to sleep on
your ideas right if you're in a jealous
mindset or hateful mindset or rageful
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are probably not the right ideas for you
but if you're in a powering empowering
inspiring positive optimistic mindset
then the ideas that come to you are the
right ones for you and just trust that
those are the right ideas and do
something on it and shortcut your brain
because as soon as your brain takes over
it's gonna be like oh okay but you don't
know how to do this and that and then
here's another problem and more
restrictions and you you know okay so
what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep him in high and then you know next
week I'll do something and then next
week comes and you haven't done it yet
right so when an idea comes to you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today
don't make it some big giant thing that
now you need a million dollars in
venture capital and a huge team to
accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
do you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
[Music]
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from John Assaraf
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there a lot of athletes
have this term around the a game and
showing up and doing their absolute best
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually Etc and it got me thinking
about do you even know what your A game